un nouveau fléau ravageur you tube à
essai zenyatta qui vous le dit de
merde
la certification zenyatta hockey euro
devient sérieux depuis plusieurs mois
une bonne partie de la communauté mais
les youtuber en pls vous voulez savoir
pourquoi les commentaires bonjour j'ai
de gros dossiers sur squeeze un jour
squeeze a tué son quoi pourquoi je peux
c'est un piège au génial ces
commentaires ont beaucoup de la car tout
le monde adore les majuscules la
raclette et les chatons
comment faire rager quelqu'un oh vous
savez qui est la personne la plus belle
au monde l'elysée le premier mot de la
phrase vous je suis flatté je t'aime un
pouce vert like si tu regardes ça
dans ton jacuzzi avec deux filles coller
à toi vous savez ce qui est le plus beau
moi je sais regarde le neuvième opus un
mail carrément offre carrément se faire
chier à trouver le neuvième manches 5 7
8 9 mois et en plus il est narcissique
mon père m'a dit que s'il me prenait
encore à aller regarder les vidéos de
squeeze il m'écraserai la tête contre le
clavier jay kay ap s'est dit lui a
écrasé la tête du coup ça fait des
lettres au pif comme ça hyper drôle
pouzère il faut que ça cesse les
commentaires ne doivent pas être un
concours de s et u2 sans gêne sur
mon commentaire par moi j'en eus 400 sur
son avant dernière vidéo full votre
attention s'il vous plaît derrière cette
intro de merde se cache un vrai message
ça fait pas mal de temps que je ne lis
plus les commentaires youtube et
pourquoi je ne les lis plus extrêmement
simple c'est parce qu'en fait je n'y
trouve plus de plaisir à élire étant
donné que les gens ne parlent plus des
vidéos ou de huskies m où ils
interagissent plus par rapport à ce que
j'ai dans la vidéo par rapport au jeu ou
à n'importe quoi les neuf dixièmes des
commentaires sont juste des gens attend
je parle des tops commentaires ceux sur
lesquels les gens mais un gros pouce
vert en dix ans jacky à ce commentaire
hélas au cul des commentaires à base de
concours de c'est-à-dire
commentaire fait pour avoir le plus de
j'aime possible on en a eu quelques-uns
là il y en a environ 600 milliards
d'autant qu'on voit et revoit sur
youtube je vais aller aux toilettes
quand je reviendrai ce commenté aura
fait le buzz
mathieu demain je vais pouvoir me la
péter du coup il ya plus aucun plaisir à
lire ses commentaires mais quand on
l'est tous les commentaires et ben on a
un peu moins de plaisir à faire des
vidéos
alors oui ce y aller vu ça fait beaucoup
de et cetera donc tu te dis que ça plaît
aux gens avec ça mais moi ce que je vois
c'est les gens qui sortent des trucs
marrants dans les commentaires mais qui
sont des blagues en rapport avec la
vidéo avec l'univers pas des gars qui
sortent des blagues universel pourra
juste avoir des pouces verts ouais je
trouve que les temps ont un peu changé
et maintenant c'est de pire en pire sur
toutes les vidéos youtube je retrouve
tout le temps ses commentaires en top
commentaires quand un milliard de pouce
vert et ceux qui sont mis en avant
malheureusement par youtube ce qui est
d'ailleurs totalement mal foutu mais ce
qui est dégueulasse c'est que ces gens
qui postent des commentaires un peu nul
sont en vrai qu'une minorité mais une
minorité assez suffisante pour que ses
commentaires et autant de pouce bella
soit mis en avant actuellement je veux
dire ça comme je peux dès que je vais
sur une vidéo je bannis tous les mecs
qui met des commentaires comme ça j'ai
même et certains mots qu'on retrouve
beaucoup dans ses commentaires là dans
les mots bannis de la chaise qui veut
dire que leurs commentaires ne passe pas
quand ils les postes mais ça change rien
on est toujours là et je crois qu'on se
dit chok tong géante organisée de
révolution à l'horaire d'organiser c'est
juste que je fais ça parce que moi ça me
ça me fait chier et je suis sûr et
certain que les 99 % des gens qui
mettent des commentaires cool ça les
fait encore plus hachée que moi parce
que poste des trucs cools ils ont envie
d'interagir avec les autres gens qui
regardent les vidéos et même avec moi
ils peuvent pas puisque leurs
commentaires sont complètement zappé à
couze commentaires pourris qui volent
des like lâchez pas y'a des gens qui ont
besoin d'une certaine reconnaissance
d'avoir pourrait avoir des gmc avoir
fait un gros buzz je sais pas je
comprends pas enfin bref voilà je
voulais vous faire passer un petit
message parce que c'est un truc qui
m'emmerde un peu et je pense même à
désactiver les commentaires sur mes
vidéos si ça continue parce que c'est la
plus de saint gély plus autant être
désactivé et qu'on fasse ça ailleurs
autrement j'en sais rien mais qu'on
trouve un truc
regardez le cordial gélita l'heure il ya
exactement le même là sauf lui il n'a
pas eu droit au pouce vert parce que 600
personnes ont mis ce commentaire là
avant lui du coup le mot père je dois le
mettre dans les mots bannis de ma chaîne
pour que tous les commentaires qui
contiennent le mot père soit dégagée de
la chaîne mais c'est complètement con
parce qu'un gars peut avoir envie de
parler de son père c'étaient les
commentaires et du coup ce qu'on va
faire a lui aussi dégagera vous
comprenez la problématique c'est
terrible ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
donc ouais je suis un peu triste en
voyant cet espace destiné à
l'interaction entre les gens à créer un
vrai une vraie ambiance cool se décliner
jour après jour jusqu'à devenir une
véritable poubelle de gens qui veulent
juste avoir des gemmes sur leurs
commentaires en bus ça sert à rien vidéo
sert à rien avant j'aime sur un
commentaire larmes en avoir des gemmes
sur un commentaire c'est pour que le
créateur de la vidéo est une chance de
votre commentaire mais quant au
commentaire n'a rien à voir avec la
vidéo le mec qu'est ce que ça peu de
foot qui le voit ou pas bref les amis
une nouvelle ère commence
cécile vanasse qui le dit j'espère qu'à
partir de maintenant ça va un petit peu
se calmer que le fait de mettre des avis
négatifs sur un commentaire ça le
dégagera complètement et que l'espace
commentaires redeviendra un espace
plutôt cool y aura toujours des petits
trucs et roux passé internet c'est
normal mais voilà que ce soit moi a
buzzé parce que je me suis un gamin
quand j'ai des commentaires il ya des
trucs super drôle y avait des gens qui
postait des tout gentil des gens qui ont
posté des mêmes des critiques ou qu'ils
erreur j'ai adoré ça j'aime bien en
faisons si on voit là il y avait des
vraies interactions des vraies idées des
vrais des vrais trucs cool qu'ils
avaient du sens finalement dans les
commentaires et classé devient juste un
gros débarras de merde
enfin non mais le peu de merde que ja
c'est ça qui est mis en avant et c'est
un gros problème c'est cool de réagir à
une vidéo avec d'autres gens dans les
commentaires c'est toujours cool et ce
truc là vient entraver sa donc évident
et je compte sur vous pour mettre des
gros pouce rouges sur les commentaires
qui ont plein de pouce vert et qu'ils
sont nuls à chier on va appeler ça les
commentaires je veux faire le buzz beach
et ben on va faire le buzz dotation de
foot akouè voilà hélas youtube mettre en
avant les commentaires constructifs et
sympa plutôt que les tirs res août à
quoi tu tues je m'arrache voilà j'ai
besoin d'en parler
finalement vous a été mon psy
aujourd'hui c'était une super science
combien je vous dois dû coup 10 400
euros la science bon gars à oreille à
ces vidéos j'espère que ça changera un
minimum je m'en fait si on agit tout ce
jeu c'est sûr et certain que ça va
changer en fait j'aime pas de questions
qui se posent en tout cas merci à tous
les autres et c'est la de grande
majorité qui posait commentaires super
cool sur les vidéos je les lis c'est
vrai que japon jamais je reconnais mais
j'en lis vraiment une bonne partie et
c'est toujours un moment de plaisir
beaucoup merci merci merci on se
retrouve dans une prochaine vidéo le
coup d'état est terminée c'est bon
oh